i wasn't like uh because i've done the
whole it's called afrika in japanese but
like the recording session
uh i guess there's like one massive
difference between the west and japan is
that in the west it's you know one at a
time
yeah yeah yeah whereas in japan it's all
together all at once right yeah and like
like you've probably done it next to
some pretty
notable people yeah yeah it's pretty
crazy like um
well it's really nerve-wracking because
like you know um
you know like like now they record it a
little bit differently
but before they used to have like 30
people or 20 to 30 30 people in like a
room in a studio
and you'll be kind of recording the
anime at the same time
and so they'll usually be like four
microphones and
you know all the actors will be like
using that microphone like
between each other yeah and so obviously
um
if like someone who's bigger than you
like your senpai is using like a mic
you can't like barge in and like you
know
so like you know you have to like look
out for your senpai's as well
and you have to like act properly as
well and you know uh so stressful
yeah i just want to work you know i
don't know
but it's so cool when like a bunch of
like super established voice actors are
doing it because like there's i think
this is like really famous youtube video
of like
all the main uh voice actors for one
piece yeah doing a scene
where all of the straw hat crew is like
talking in a scene
yeah and they're just so fluidly like
switching between microphones when
they're like rolls come up and stuff
because like
what i did as well is that like just
because you're not on the microphone it
doesn't mean you're not
acting because a lot of the times people
who aren't on the microphone
are used for like crowd noises like just
passes by and stuff like that and it's
like
so you're constantly just like being
ridiculous
as well when you're trying to act to
have like someone kind of providing the
feel of the scene to you
you know yeah i feel like that's why
conor suba especially works really well
because
you hear like you you hear the original
like japanese dub of it
and it kind of like you can tell that
the actresses and actors are just
bouncing off each other
really naturally and it's like hard to
tell it's actually
it's actually some points where it's
hard to tell if it's actually scripted
or just like completely
um improvised sometimes they used to do
a lot more
for english productions but you know
scheduling is a nightmare yeah
yeah yeah yeah and for stuff like you
know like a disney movie if you have
like all these
aaa actors it's impossible to get them
all at the same room at the same time
but some some movies and some shows
still do it
but it used to be a lot more common but
now it's not really it's not long
because i've seen like footage of like
like toy story and stuff like that like
all the actors for toy story were all in
the same room like kind of in a semi
circle and they all just had like a mic
and like a stand for their scriptures
it's normally the more expensive the
production the more you can do that
yeah if you have more money you can tell
hey come in oh you know for movies
they'll always do a like a table read
right
yeah the actors will come in they'll
just practice it together even if
they're not recording together yeah
stuff like that the scary thing is
because
like you know um once the anime
recording starts it's like
you have to like stay silent even when
it's not like your turn to speak so
like um even when you're reading the
script and you know it's not your turn
and
you want to like turn the page over you
have to be really careful
and like and like um when you walk up to
the microphone
you can't make any sound so like you
know even with your clothing
it has to be something that doesn't make
sound like
you know yeah you can't be wearing like
leather jackets and like you know
stuff like that just like hello
they used to have like a box just full
of like really old t-shirts
really all the studios i worked at and
they were just like if you if you wore
anything that wasn't a t-shirt they'd
like put the t-shirt on
wow that doesn't sound sanitary it was
just wearing someone's sweaty t-shirt
right wash them
but it was just like they were like
don't don't bring anything that isn't a
t-shirt because it makes too much noise
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and i don't have keys in
your pocket or anything like that
like just empty your pockets because i
hate to be that guy who just like came
on and i was like
[ __ ] i need to sneeze right now
and i feel that like the pressure is
even greater because it's like
if you [ __ ] up a line for instance yeah
then all the actors are there to kind of
like
so what happens if someone flubs that
line well that happens um because
we're recording like you know like i
think i think we record like
each 15 minutes of an anime so like um
if you like mess up your line you just
stay silent and just
back away have you ever done that
yeah like
i could see like the ptsd in her face as
she was like telling the story i was
like oh
she's experiencing this it's like um if
you mess up you can't see like oops or
anything like that you just have to like
stay silent so the person after you can
say their lines
and so like once also they can just like
cut your hair yeah and then they can
make sense take it again after the whole
15 minutes is like
recorded right so yeah and it's really
uh it's really hard because when you
first start voice acting right
the director tells you like you know we
want that line said
more like this way or like you know in a
different way to what you did
and if you're not like able to like
you know say it like how the director
wants you to say it you like take it
again and again
but you're taking it again and again
right in front of all your senpai's
so like you're taking their time and you
know the director's like um
uh we want it more like this way and
you're like okay um
and so yeah it's really so
nerve-wracking like yeah that's that's
like
too that's like pressure on top of
pressure like you're already pressured
to be like
i'm gonna nail my line just so i can put
on a good performance like the teacher
going all right what's the answer
or you you you specifically what is the
answer to this math question you don't
know come on
you can do it come on come on
have you had like the director explain
how they want you to do the line
differently and you're like what
that does not make any sense uh yeah
when i was first like
in an uh anime um
one of the directors told me uh like in
japanese they said mochio
chambarami taini and yeah and i was like
because i was like what does that mean
is like like like soft
like sword yeah okay with like like yeah
so basically like play sword
yeah yeah yeah sound more play sword
fight yeah
that's so specific yeah and i was like
and and at that time i was like i didn't
know the word chambada
it would be so awkward to ask the
director what does chambora mean right
i was like okay i'll try my best and so
i asked the person next to me who was
around the same age as me
and yeah she told me and it still didn't
make any sense
what does that mean like how did you how
to find out what he wanted
um i'm not sure
i've wondered what the tape should have
been but i got an okay so
i guess i was able to you know was that
an okay or was that like
okay
it could be either one right yeah when
you're doing lines sometimes there's
that feeling of like you're not getting
it and then you just you just
you know personally you're not gonna get
it and then they're just like
i would move on and i'm like no yeah why
tell me yeah i get that feeling here
have you ever like said like a line and
that you you've just been like
that was an awful take and the
director's been like all right we're
moving on yeah that's a good take
yeah yeah i've had that a lot okay
and that's why you should say like [ __ ]
at the end of my life right if i hated
it but then they would tell you to stop
saying [ __ ] because they're ruining the
line that they liked
because you'd be like yeah [ __ ] because
then you couldn't use it